Jason I believe when we initially
interviewed you during the summer you
said that when you started your YouTube
channel it was your goal to leave your
day job
it sounds like a wonderful cold yes I
think everybody wants to do that um what
would you tell people in the same boat
before you were actually able to do that
what do they need to know what are some
unrealistic goals or excuse me
expectations that we go on
you know I what I did was when I was
working my day job I made sure I did
three things everyday for my career you
know the youtubes whatever it is and I
knew that I eventually was gonna leave
the shop I didn't want to it's like
dating someone and then you let yourself
kind of get out of shape and you kind of
like you know lose contact with your
friends and your interest and then you
get broken up with it you're left kind
of like fat sad and have no options so
stay in shape have great relationships
this way if you get broken up with or
get like you know you lose your job
you're ready to hit the ground running
so kind of be ready to kind of slowly
kind of integrate other stuff you know I
read a great article on the onion about
like you know do you love on your free
time in weekends you know it doesn't
mean you have to quit your job it
doesn't mean you don't have to not do it
so kind of always be ready to kind of
engage what you want to do if you lose
your job or if you decide you want to
quit your job but you know quitting you
know the world doesn't owe you anything
no one no one cares unless you make them
care that's the one big thing like no
one cares about my stuff unless I'm a
unless they make them care about what
about what I do so be prepared to you
know whether it's saving money or be
prepared to take side jobs you might not
want to do like when I left my job you
know it's great like I make a lot of my
money you know I make all of my money
doing comedy related stuff now with that
not everything I do I love you know I
mean there's things that I've done that
I was just like in the entertainment
thing but like I really want to do this
but you know what I need that money to
do other things
um so be prepared to be prepared to do
what you can to like live your dream I
guess well you said that you always knew
that you would be able to cross
you seem like a realist to me huh
absolutely very great and that you you
always probably realize the downside of
Thanos how did you know though that that
was going to happen because so many
people come here with those same plans
and it doesn't manifest yeah that's the
thing about me is I came to LA kind of
like you know I didn't come like as a
kid so I am and you know I worked I knew
like full you know had a 401k and and
you know I've always been kind of
creative and I don't know I came kind of
like it was very like a working class
like just weren't you know came for I
came from New York I was like and not to
say that everyone's working class and
has good workout things but I came and
just very realistic like just you know I
don't I don't care about stuff I don't
care about things I just know what I
love and I believe that other people
will and I don't expect them to but if I
get a chance and I knew I would get my
chance that it would kind of come to
fruition yeah I just knew but I was
really I was pretty smart about it I
wasn't like hey people in my hometown
and my mom thinks I'm funny so everyone
else is gonna there's this you know
there's no shortage you know of hope
there's no shortage of talented people
hilarious comedians good-looking people
people that can direct and write and
create but you just kind of have to be
able to work harder than that person
that does the same thing like right
below you
you know sometimes why have you seen
people or ever even subscribe to some
your own theory that you know yeah
someone's just gonna choose me and I'm
just gonna hang out and you know talk
amongst friends or yeah I see a lot of
that in LA a lot of getting out a lot of
people going to films and all that's
great
yeah but they kind of think that they'll
be is someone will see them did I choose
them absolutely I mean I look I know I
look at myself in the mirror I was like
I wouldn't look at me and give me
anything so I I don't I don't believe in
that I believe that um I can create
stuff was something like YouTube I don't
have to prove anything to you like if
somebody's like you know can you do this
and I consider a video and you know
point to a number I've been in a meeting
I did a commercial for Sony and they
were just like how do i how do we know
you can do this I pull I just you know
turn on the big monitor like thinking in
a conference room pulled up a video and
I walked over I pointed to a
number and I sat down I was like that's
how I know and I have I have you know my
resume you people send their resumes and
it's like it's just words I can send a
resume for my acting writing
collaboration brand integration of
series producing anything pretty much
anything hosting I can send you an
example and show a level of success to
that and that's not people looking at me
and asked me like hey you look like
you'd be great right I heard you were
really great it's just like I just do
good work and and I understand the
business of it and then the people the
word gets around it's a you know it's a
volume game so you're not waiting for
anyone to choose you I absolutely not if
you know there was a point where I was I
felt kind of like 6 anyone gonna notice
me and then I started putting things out
and not caring about that and then
people will notice if you do good work
people are gonna know especially on
YouTube with the internet it gets it
gets around people are gonna be like I
met so many who were like I love your
stuff and I'm always surprised was like
really you know who I am like and then
you know and it's not even just in the
in the Hollywood YouTube comedy thing I
mean you know I'll be getting an oil
change somebody's like hey man I really
you know I really love you I really love
your videos and they're not you they're
just like yeah I just happen to watch
your I like YouTube stuff and your
videos kind of come across so making the
people that make and I'm not really one
of them for the most part but people
that kind of make that transition from
outside Hollywood outside YouTube
outside kind of the internet space into
kind of hey this just ended up on my
Facebook page and I'm just think you
know a guy that works in an office I
think that that's that's really success
especially in YouTube
you